alright I'm not busting out the red
lightsaber this time because I'm not
feeling quite as evil about it right now
so I'm gonna talk Star Wars again no I
haven't seen the last Jedi a second time
no I haven't changed my opinion about
that movie but I have gone back and
taken another look at what the continued
box office numbers have been since I did
a video previously talking about its
drop-off from its first week to its
second week I feel like looking at the
more long-term numbers maybe it deserves
a little bit of a recent reassessment
because before looking strictly at the
second weekend drop off it didn't look
good and honestly I had said at the time
and I think it probably still happened
to a certain extent that I said that
there was probably a lot of scrambling
going on at Lucasfilm and at Disney
trying to figure out the best way to
deal with what was clearly a problem in
a very divisive movie again I don't want
to get into an argument about how good
or bad it was I just want I want to
mainly talk about the future and using
the box office as a leaping off point
now having looked at the first four
weekends worth of decline and drop off
because of all films have drop off as
they go along and compare you to a few
other things the picture is not as bad
as it looked
previously so like I said the initial
second weekend drop-off was big it was
close to BBS numbers but there's a
couple things sort of caveats to stick
on that there's one thing that I don't
view it this way but it's worth
addressing and some people even
mentioned it in the comic and comments
which is that some people count
Christmas itself onto that second
weekend because for many people it was a
four-day weekend and I don't like to do
that especially when you're talking
about decline as opposed to an opening
weekend when you're opening on a holiday
weekend but if we do take that into
account obviously you are adding another
day on to it it is a less steep decline
doing that but even if we're not
acknowledging that the drop-off and the
subsequent weekends was not nearly as
dramatic
and I mean drop-off can level off
anyways but look here's some comparisons
I looked at the box office numbers for
the force awakens the last Jedi and then
for point of reference compared them to
Justice League and Batman V Superman and
regardless of how those other movies
opened they did drop more precipitously
than was certainly desired by Warner
Brothers in the case of those releases
so comparing them all together so the
one that had the best retention by a
pretty good margin was the force awakens
average decline over a you know four
weeks worth of drop off was about 42%
which that is a good that is a good
average for for weekend's worth of drop
off and the force awakens had a really
good audience retention that thing had
legs in addition to opening huge now the
last Jedi depending on whether or not
you're counting in the four-day weekend
for the second weekend um it will vary
so if you're gonna count that which I
don't but if you're going to then the
average drop off for the last Jedi comes
in at about forty seven percent if you
don't count that extra day which I
honestly I feel like it's cheating but
so the way that I would calculate it
then it comes in at about fifty percent
for point of reference Justice League
over for weekend's how to drop off
average of about fifty three percent and
then BBS had about fifty six
I'm not picking B vs and Justice League
just to pick on Warner Brothers I'm
doing it because the response to those
movies led to Warner Brothers
reassessing everything that they were
doing so the reason I picked those
numbers is because those numbers are
reflective of numbers that cause the
studio to change its plans so that's why
I want to use that as a comparison
because that's what I want to sort of
drive this conversation right now is is
Lucasfilm going to reassess and
massively change their plans or are they
going to stay the course because right
now they're the numbers for the last
Jedi kind of fall in the middle whether
or not they lean more
closer to say Justice League rather than
force awakens' or if they're closer to
force awakens that depends on whether or
not you want to you want to give them an
extra day or not but regardless it is in
the middle of the of force waste force
awakens and Justice League it's just a
question of sort of where which one it's
closer to so as I said last time I
talked about the box office numbers and
the last Jedi I said you know they are
gonna be scrambling probably trying to
figure out what to do now they may not
be scrambling as harshly because the the
numbers the drop off seems to have
leveled off a little bit in the
subsequent weekends that being said I
have little doubt that if not Kathleen
Kennedy herself that certainly some of
the higher-ups at Disney probably really
want a less divisive film for episode 9
so there's probably some reassessment
going on there how they tackle that I
don't know I mean I said before that I
don't I don't want episode 9 I don't
want JJ Abrams to deliberately undo
episode 8 because then you're just gonna
end up with the single most disjointed
little mini trilogy like ever so I I
mean I don't want that I don't envy him
trying to continue on from the last Jedi
and that's not just because I have a lot
of issues with the movie it didn't end
in a way that felt like there was too
many places to go especially without
Carrie Fisher to sort of be the the
spearhead of the last film which was the
original plan back when the Colin
Trevorrow was gonna do it I think right
now in a lot of ways there's probably a
fairly heavy amount of faith in Kathleen
Kennedy from the higher-ups I'm not
talking about fans that is probably
gonna be either permanently shaken or
reaffirmed depending on what happens
with solo now I've said already I do not
expect solo to be good but whether or
not it's good doesn't necessarily
translate to whether or not it is
successful however they're they're going
in with a handicap on that one
they are they're not in a good position
because there's obviously there was the
very public firing of the original
directors and massive reshoots had to
happen which no doubt up to the cost of
the dang thing which was probably not a
cheap movie in the first place
so already they spent way more money on
that movie than they probably originally
planned to and that was done largely on
the pledge that the script that Lord and
Miller the original directors weren't
sticking to was so good in the fact that
they wouldn't stick to it cause the
concern so if it comes out and if box
office is wonky that's not good if the
critics say it's bad like it's a bad
story then it's really for me as a fan
gonna remove whatever little remaining
faith I have in Kathleen Kennedy and her
ability to Shepherd this project overall
um that I might still have in place
because that to me says that she made a
decision based on her assessment of the
quality of a script and it wasn't a good
script now I don't know if that would be
the case I'll have to see the movie to
know whether or not that's the case it
may turn out to be a really good script
and well I'm not gonna say that would
suddenly restore my faith in Kathleen
Kennedy that would help certainly
because here's the thing about Kathleen
Kennedy say what you will about George
Lucas when he was shepherding the other
films because remember though he
directed all the prequels with that
original trilogy he only directed the
first one himself and then the second
and third he was a very hands-on
producer and even though it's very clear
that a lot of his decisions were being
made with toys and merchandising in mind
he was still the original creative force
and he cared and that's not for me to
say that Kathleen Kennedy doesn't care I
think she probably does but she's not
coming at it from the perspective of a
creator she's not coming at it from the
perspective of an artist she's coming at
it from the perspective of the person
maintaining the franchise she's come at
it from with a producer with an
executives perspective and I and again
that's not inherently a bad thing that's
just that's the perspective Kevin Feige
just marvel with but I think we're
seeing the difference we're seeing how
George Lucas retaining that art that
artistic perspective that ownership of
the original creation as part of his
perspective Leni produced Empire and
Jedi that is now kind of absent because
he there there was a little bit more
really making sure that it made sense
with what it was that he had done
originally whereas and again a fair
amount of his calculation was also how
do I make money off this because say
what you will about George Lucas as a
filmmaker he hasn't always been great
but he is a savvy businessman and he was
really good at that but he did still
have that other element where as
Kathleen Kennedy is just the
businessperson
um and good at it look I'm not gonna
take that away from her but I think
we're feeling the absence of someone
like George Lucas and that's not me
saying like George come back and save
this I'm just saying that somebody with
the background that he has and what
Kathleen Kennedy doesn't have that he
did I think what we were feeling that
absence right now the main thing that I
think is probably in a better shape than
it was before is that I I had thought
that if the decline we can over weekend
decline at the box office
continued to be in the you know upper
50s into the 60s range that it might
jeopardize Ryan Johnson's standalone
trilogy that they're talking about I
think he's probably pretty safe to at
least get his first one made at this
point and then subsequent ones will be
judged off the response to that one I
think if if the decline had been had
continued to be as steep as it was
instead of leveling out in terms of the
box office I think it would have been an
open question whether or not he was
actually gonna get to do that I think at
this point he probably will unless
unless say say solo bombs
unless Disney steps in and removes
Kathleen Kennedy put somebody else in
ryan johnson is gonna get
make at least his first film in this
standalone trilogy which I am in favor
of cuz for all my issues with the last
Jedi I do find Rian Johnson's take and
his instincts about this universe to be
intriguing I just wish they have been
applied to a side project from the
get-go as opposed to being injected into
the primary saga so you know I don't
begrudge him what he did I kind of
begrudge Kathleen Kennedy for letting
him do it because I feel like the flow
of the saga has been massively disrupted
by the last jet I am what it was doing
and for how different Rian Johnson
wanted to be yeah I think they just
should have put him on the on these side
things right off the bat so but I I do I
do actually want to see you know what he
has in mind for this thing I still wish
that he hadn't made the last Jedi but
that doesn't mean I don't want to see
what else he has to offer now that he's
off of the main saga and of course the
other thing to worry about in all this
is episode 9 and I just worry how much
of its gonna be reactive based off the
response to episode 8 and and again III
say this even as someone who has a lot
of issues with episode 8 but I just I
don't want the decision-making process
of episode 9 to be from a starting place
of we have to fix what just happened it
has to start from a place of this is the
story that we want to tell because it's
a good story for these characters if you
can also make adjustments that you feel
are correctives or answer criticisms on
the previous one great but you can't
start from that place when your concern
is answering criticisms or responding to
what people thought about your previous
movie if that comes in too early in the
process
if you prioritize that over figuring out
just a good story you you're not gonna
end up with a great film you're just not
so whatever is happening I really hope
JJ Abrams is he's pouring his energy and
working his writing room into a frenzy
about coming up with a great story not
we need to fix what happened and I and I
know a lot of fans are like he
to fix this like look maybe he can maybe
he can't maybe it does need to be fixed
maybe it doesn't but he cannot be
focused on answering fan complaints he
has to prioritize finding the thread and
finding the story because you know the
original plan like I said was to have it
focus on Carrie Fisher that's gone they
need a new angle they need a good strong
story because if if Carrie Fisher was
still around and they were able to just
go well it's gonna be Leia's not maybe
not centric but lay a heavy the way that
the episode eight was luke heavy in the
way that episode 7 was Han heavy episode
9 is gonna be Leia heavy and if she was
still around they could go okay we know
this so we've got that as our starting
point how can we also address the the
criticisms of the previous movie now
that she's gone they don't even have a
foundation to start from you they don't
have a grounding to start going oh how
do we deal with criticisms like you need
to build new foundation first but I'm
gonna continue to keep an eye on this
but I just think overall it was worth
pointing out that the box-office
declined leveled off and the whole thing
is probably not in as big of a shake-up
mode as it potentially could have been I
do think what happens with solo could
shake things up further especially if it
bombs which I'm not gonna make a
prediction that it will but I think
between the questionable idea in the
first place the fact that they moved it
off of a December release and they're
putting it in the middle of summer where
it's gonna have to actively compete with
everything as opposed to simply owning
December which Star Wars has done for
the last three years I still don't
understand that move and then the very
public turmoil that the production went
through I think there is a fair chance
that solo could flop and then if it does
we could be looking at a serious
reconfiguration maybe not to the scale
of what is happening with Warner
Brothers in DC because there's still
there's solid foundational work that
Star Wars has that DS
see basically with making their movie
franchise
they built Foundation and then started
off on this whole project without
realizing nobody likes their foundation
so even if even if Star Wars gets a big
shake-up it's not gonna be to that
degree I don't think but if solo bombs
things could really get thrown into even
more chaos than they have been and that
that kind of bums me out and Star Wars
in general has become a topic that it's
like I'm not enthusiastic to talk about
anymore but I did say I did still want
to acknowledge this because you know
what I had said before about how the box
up has dropped off in the meaning of
that I I needed to redress that because
what happened to the box office in the
weekend subsequent didn't bear out my
original thesis so I needed to come back
and discuss it so barring any major
details announcement I probably am NOT
gonna talk Star Wars again until the
first trailer for solo comes out and
then you know we'll see what I think
from there but that is all I've got for
right now Star Wars the box office its
future all that stuff what do you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it do all those things you
know the likes the subscribes I'm on
Twitter I got an email I got a patreon
now whatever it is you want to check out
links is for everything is down below so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]